so about five or six weeks ago on
December 15th it was two days after
Democrat Doug Jones defeated Republican
Roy Moore in that Alabama special Senate
election I did a story that we called
Democrats should target Ted Cruz in 2018
Cruz as I've mentioned is one of the
most vile Republican senators in the
United States there's that angle there's
the angle of these sort of demographic
shifts that are taking place in Texas
and there's a number of movements that
are trying to turn Texas blue a lot of
interesting reasons to maybe look at
2018 as a good year to target someone
like Ted Cruz who is running a Senate
re-election campaign and there's a new
poll and it's admittedly a democratic
poll which has in Kunda incumbent
Republican senator Ted Cruz leading the
Democratic sort of frontrunner it hasn't
been a primary yet but the Democratic
frontrunner to face Ted Cruz is Beto
O'Rourke by only 10 points according to
this poll in Texas with 18 percent of
the electorate undecided or Cruz is
ahead by only eight points 45 to 37 now
again it's a democratic poll from a
group called n Citizens United which is
a campaign reform group there's a
contrasting poll it's an internal one
from Ted Cruz's campaign and usually
these internal polls are the most
favorable to the candidate remember back
in the 2012 presidential election Mitt
Romney we learned was totally shocked by
losing to Barack Obama on election night
because he was heavily focused on these
internal polls that his own campaign was
doing and they did not reflect reality
so there's an internal Ted Cruz poll
that has Cruz ahead by 18 points so the
Democratic poll has Cruz ahead by 8 the
Ted Cruz poll has Cruz ahead by 18
that's a 10-point swing from one poll to
the other so what can we be sure of we
can be sure that this is an uphill
battle it's not going to be like the
Alabama special election this is not a
special election first and foremost and
unlike in Alabama the Ted Cruz Ted
Cruz's candidacy is not the candidacy of
an accused serial child sex assault
right whatever Ted Cruz has in his
background it's at least not public so
it's a very very different situation it
has been 30 years since 1988 and that's
the last time that a Democrat won a cell
at a Senate election in Texas and Cruz
has been in this seat since 2012 but
it's not impossible right if Ted Cruz
has some kind of scandal hit in the next
few months
anything could happen so I think this is
an interesting race yeah maybe if he
starts liking more porn videos where's
in Texas will turn against them yes or
you mean being hacked all right there's
a staffer it was yeah that's the
official story what can you do well you
could donate to Beto O'Rourke actor and
David Pakman show fan John Leguizamo
announced that he has been donating
daily 25 bucks a day to Beto or Rourke
you can get involved in the campaign if
you're in Texas or even if you're not
eventually you would be able to phone
Bank after the primary but you've got a
vote right and to participate in the
primary in Texas you need to register by
February 5th that's coming up the
primary is March 6th and then to vote in
the November election you have to
register by October 9th so still plenty
of time for that I don't want to pretend
that this is some easy seat to turn from
red to blue but the significance if it
were to happen would be monumental and
if we believe the Democratic poll we're
a better or work is down 8 points let's
call it down 10 points to be more
conservative 9 months to go that means
he needs to make up about 1 point per
month it's not impossible but you've got
to start working on it now and it's a US
Senate seat so that's you know important
in and of itself yeah but it would also
mean the end of Ted Cruz's political
career would be huge in many ways and
that's a big deal it counts as a
Democrat in Texas it counts as one of
the hundred Senate votes in the Senate
and just getting rid of Ted Cruz is
absolutely fantastic it's something we
should all aspire to and better or work
also has the right positions on many
issues right he would be an asset in the
Senate pro-choice wants stimulus
spending wants more science teachers in
school and funding for them he's strong
on the climate he wants citizens
automatically registered to vote and to
end voter
Eydie AKA voter suppression laws point
of it is this is one of many interesting
races that you can get involved in all
435 members of the House are up for
reelection one third of the 100 senators
are up for re-election so please get
involved that's the main message from me
the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
you can make a pledge of as little as
one dollar per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad